okay so spider-man 2 is filled with
easter eggs hidden details and things
you missed the movie is almost 20 years
old now but with no way home bringing
toby mcguire on out for molina back you
know we had to revisit it there's even
possible callbacks in the doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness trailer and
though there's been a ton of breakdowns
made on the film i guarantee there's a
lot in here that hasn't been found
before now melina's dark ark pulls from
several of the classic stories he's been
included in over the years however at
the time they somewhat wanted to
modernize the version of him and they
looked at the ultimate spider-man run
which had released just four years prior
in that darkhawk ends up trying to turn
norman osborn into a super soldier but
it backfires and transforms him into the
green goblin in the explosion ock is
blinded and the operating arms he wears
are fused to his body raymie cribbed
massive bits from his recovery and in
the comics several surgeons stand around
him about to operate they place a
bandage over his eyes which is two
mirrored in the movie just before they
begin hawk ends up killing them in a
violent bloody massacre which is too
brought up in the film in a scene that
raymie is really allowed to dig into his
horror roots with it's reminiscent of
the evil dead franchise and that even
features a mini surgical powered sword
which is of course a nod to ash's
chainsaw much in the same way that arc
is possessed ash's hand was taken over
too in the second film which he replaced
with the weapon we should get our own
mechanical arms to help with reaches
like that but you might not know that
one of the surgeons is john landis a
fellow horror director behind thriller
and american werewolf in london now the
ultimate comics might even somewhat
explain why awkward sunglasses
throughout the movie as we learn the
explosion damaged his eyes to the point
that they were extremely sensitive to
light standing in front of the miniature
sun may have also potentially caused him
to walk around in the film like he's
annie in the terminator though he does
remove the glasses in the more
humanizing moments either way there's a
ton of callbacks to comics in this movie
and this is shown early on in the intro
as we watch the credits roll in we can
catch several pieces of artwork by alex
ross that tell the story of the previous
movie like mary jane's fiance ross was
somewhat jilted at the altar as he
actually designed his own version of the
suit for spider-man 1 but this was
scrapped in favor of the one that was
finally used to make good on dropping
him at the last minute though sony
reached back out to ross and asked him
to make the title sequence for the film
it features 15 pieces of artwork and
work by ross also pops up later in the
movie in harry osborn's documents on
spidey we end the credits with the scene
in which peter walked away from mj like
she walked away from john jameson but
it's clear that he still thinks about
her a lot now the opening scene has a
face blown up on a perfume advert for
emma rose in the comics mary jane of
course worked as a model but beyond that
emma rose is actually the name of remy's
daughter now in spider-man 2 mary jane
is a very important character and her
relationship with peter looms over the
movie which is established in the
opening shot however the reason it's
used here is symbolic on a number of
levels this movie actually ends with an
opposite to this and just in the same
way that we open with mary jane we close
out on her too there are definitely
parallels here and whereas in the
opening peter is the one looking over
mary jane come the end of it she watches
over him as he swings through the sky
the ad for mj is prestigious white and
pristine whereas dikovich's door has the
white paint cracking away and that's why
i'm refusing to pay the rent this month
mj also looks somewhat sad in this final
shot because she's now confronted with
the reality of how life will be but in
the beginning she's smiling due to the
manufactured ad that she's a part of
it's really good storytelling from
raymie and if you're enjoying the video
so far we'd massively appreciate the
thumbs up if this is your first time
here then welcome to the heavy spoiler
show i'm your host paul aka the guy who
holds the power of the pun in the palm
of his hand and the real crime would be
not to finish what we started so with
that of the way let's get into the rest
of the video now after the intro we see
that peter is late for his job at joe's
pizza located on bleecker street you
might know this famous road from being
the same place where dr strange's
sanctum sanctuarum is sam raimi is of
course a director for in the multiverse
of madness and there's another doctor
strange easter egg that comes later on
in the film at the daily bugle sam
raimi's brother ted suggests the name
doctor stranger j jonah jameson when
they're brainstorming ideas for what
they should call otto
what are we gonna call this guy uh uh
doctor octopus that's crap uh science
squid crap
doctor strange that's pretty good
but it's taken
wait wait i got it
doctor octopus but i like it of course
you do jameson says it's good but it's
taken and as i've been saying for now
it's all connected stop it's pizza time
now we watch as peter zips through the
city trying to deliver joe's pizza in a
moment that made some of the best
missions in the spider-man 2 game
cameoing in the scene is donnell
rawlings a comedian that you might
recognize from chipotle's show there's
also a slice out lance on a guy's
balcony and this man is actually scott
spiegel the co-writer of evil dead 2.
now sadly peter delivers the pizza light
and he gets fired from his job he then
gets fired by jameson but he ends up
giving him photos of spider-man against
his better judgement in order to keep up
their friendly relationship now later on
in the movie jameson is given the
spider-man suit by someone who finds it
in the trash the guy talks about how he
could sell it on ebay and this is
actually a note to the real life story
about the suits that got stolen from the
set of the first film the thief managed
to nap three of them and he tried to
sell him on ebay which calls back to
this line spider-man suit being left in
the trash is actually also a reference
to spider-man no more a storyline in
which peter stepped away from being the
web head the mask was dumped in the
rubbish along with all my jokes and it
could be seen hanging out of it as being
a walk down an alleyway much like how he
does in this movie no way home would
somewhat given odd to this too and when
norman osborne seemingly quits being the
green goblin he smashes the mask at a
dumpster before fleeing down an alleyway
now this point peter asks for money from
betty brandt like he's going to the bank
and this is an easter egg because she's
played by elizabeth banks great easter
eggs
[Laughter]
are you serious now in the comics betty
brunt worked as a secretary for the
daily bugle however in brand new day she
became a reporter in a neat touch
showing the different realities and
timelines the betty brown of the mcu
became a reporter for the daily bugle
during spider-man noah home which is
also based on the brand new day's
storyline now peter being late for
things is pretty much a running joke in
the movie get it running because he's
always running everywhere and i'm moving
on from that i won't bunny mrs doctor
conan's lecturer at columbia university
and connors is of course the lizard from
the comics sam raimi's fourth spider-man
movie was cancelled by sony and dylan
baker later confirmed to ign that he was
supposed to play the scaly beast in that
film sony of course rebooted the full
franchise and though they got rid of the
entire cast they kept the lizard it's
the villain blizzard of course appeared
in no way home and no we didn't get the
snout version from the comics it's
probably unlikely that we would have had
it in the fourth movie anyway it from my
uncle you know the guy works at sony
sent me a copy of spider-man home alone
2 lost in new york so you know he's a
good guy well he said the animal mouths
are more difficult to animate with
convincing human voices so they
purposely made the face more human
looking so it wasn't too weird probably
it would have ended up looking like rex
from toy story so it does make sense why
they kept the design in that movie
instead of making him more like a
talking alligator now at this point
peter goes to his birthday party and he
gets his crunk on we discover that he no
longer lives with harry and if he casts
your mind back to the first movie you
might remember that peter lived with him
in an apartment this was paid for him by
norman osborne but after he ended up
stabbing himself in the balls peter now
has to live with mr dickovich mr
dikovich is actually named after steve
ditko who co-created spider-man with
stan lee and may then gives peter twenty
dollars twenty dollars the ad said three
thousand shortly after peter gets
introduced to otto by harry connors has
already told him about him and that he's
brilliant but lazy peter's response to
this is that he's trying to do better
cutting our way home when the pair
interact once more at the statue of
liberty and peter says the same thing
parker now i remember you your connor
student
tells me you're brilliant
he also tells me you're lazy
i'm trying to do better well being
brilliant is not enough young man you
have to work hard you're all grown up
how are you
trying to do better
oh shout outs to canadian lad for
pointing out that before peter ronaldo
duel using their tech and powers they
first engage in a battle of wits peter
then mentions bernoulli and the curves
of the quickest descent in the simplest
explanation it's an equation that
explains the quickest point between a
and b as a curve as on a curve you
generate more speed this is of course
something that spidey does to get around
as he swings in an arc and this is
probably why it's in his head at this
moment at this point otto tells us how
he and rosie met saying that she
attempted to help him understand t.s
eliot eliot's most famous line is
arguably this is the way the world ends
not with a bang but a whimper appearing
in the hollow men it's often used to
describe humanity's ending being
somewhat unceremonious however this line
actually foreshadows otto's death at the
end of the movie in which he drowns the
miniature son along with himself in the
hudson now shout out to eric boss and
your rock stars for spotting that and
shouts mt philip molina and the rest of
the team for being generally great
blokes unlike that bloody a bloody
ryanairy you chump see ya chump
now otto of course arrives from a river
and no way home and this is actually the
same one that he died in during this
movie there's also a nice line in which
he hints towards his final scene after
his experiment fails
and these
monstrous things should be at the bottom
of the river
our order tells peter that the way to
get girls to like you is through poetry
which is the worst advice ever peter
then ends up reading a poem by henry
woodsworth longfellow and it goes down
worse than the jokes in this video
ladies get ready because the line reads
day by day he gazed upon her day by day
he side with passion that's the sound of
a thousand women leaving their man for
daddy kevin's spoilers just kidding yeah
no women watch this channel i've got the
analytics anyway this parallels the
relationship between peter and mary jane
much like the poem he loves her from
before and she's always just out of
reach peter then ends up late for mj's
play where she's acting in the
importance of being earnest originally
created by oscar wilde the piece is
about double lives and in a bit of an
on-the-nose metaphor she's asked about
forgiving as she looks at peter's vacant
seat 65 minutes later in the movie when
peter rejects his life as spider-man he
goes to the play and puts mj off the
line in this scene is discussing living
double lives something that peter has
for now at least stop doing by walking
away from the role at the theater is
inertia played by bruce campbell who
appears in all three movies much like
the lizard campbell had a role lined up
for spider-man 4 and he was actually
supposed to be playing none other than
mysterio kind of makes sense that he has
all these different roles as he's the
master of illusions but i kind of just
like to think he's like a stanley sort
of figure i'd love to see him pop up in
the multiverse of madness at some point
and potentially he's one of the members
of the illuminati council we want a
doctor strange variant now outside
licking his emotional wounds peter hears
a god-awful violinist playing the
spider-man theme song this appeared in
the first film as well when a busker
busted it out and it was the theme song
for the 1967 cartoon peter's hardest
rift in two and seeing mary jane with
her new boyfriend but ignore all that
yet and instead focus on the poster
that's praising the play saying j
frasier is especially effective jay
frasier or john frasier worked on the
special effects which is the category
the first movie won an oscar for this
easter egg is particularly effective
because it says effective and special
effects
yeah yeah you get it you funk now after
seeing the love of his life with another
man a boy loses his mojo he has
performance issues with his web fluid
which we've all been there and he also
loses his sight this is very much
psychosomatic and brought on by the
feeling of inadequacy that he has in
general he sees mj everywhere but can't
be with her and this is quite literally
shown when peter carries his trash bike
past the wall of the same advert that we
saw at the start not long after we get
otto's experiment and the classic joke
about the money in a rubber band before
we start has anybody lost a large roll
of 20 bills in a rubber band
because we found the rubber band
it's a terrible joke
but thank you for coming
now seriously though if you've seen the
money yeah can can you please give it
back anyway otto is unable to stabilize
the sun and rosie ends up dying if
you've seen the trailer for in the
multiverse of madness you will know that
we get a cool shot of wonders eyes and
visions of multiversal characters in
glass when rosie dies we see her
reflection in shadow glass and the glass
hits her eyes which may be raymie
linking back to this movie otto also
says the power of the sun in the palm of
my hands which he drops on the bridge
and later on in the way home toby
finishes the line linking back to this
moment now at the bank ant-may and peter
come face to face with joe mchale she
lies and says she's giving piano lessons
once more and shouts bp8r07 for pointing
out that this explains why peter is so
good at playing piano in spider-man 3.
probably taught him to dance as well and
at this point honor robs the bank you
might notice that the eyes on the
tentacles turn red when in attack mode
but when otto is in control they turn
white this is also referenced later in
nowhere home during the bridge scene and
throughout most of the movie at one
point in the fight ock goes to crush
peter's head with the arms and this
moment would also be referenced on the
bridge when he also tries to do the same
thing with tom holland's version the
late great stan lee also appears outside
the bank near a taxi when olive and
peter fight and he moves someone out the
way falling debris which he also does in
the first spider-man movie at this
special gala that peter is asked to
cover for the society pages we get a
glimpse at jonah's son and mj's fiance
john jameson the chump see you chump now
in the comics he became manwell after
coming back from the moon which is
somewhat referenced when we learn that
he's an astronaut in the opening of
venom we also discover that one of the
returning astronauts is called jameson
which is likely the same character just
in a different universe you know fully
loses his mojo at this point he crashes
down and then sees a daily bugle
headline the front page appears for a
split second but if you pause the film
you'll see that the article says can
chronic back pain equal brain shrinkage
now i'm sure many of you know the story
but just in case you don't toby mcguire
actually sustained a back injury during
the filming of seabiscuit this led to
him almost departing spider-man 2 and
jake gyllenhaal was poised to take over
the role this is then referenced again
when he jumps across the buildings and
he says i'm back and then says my back
now we know that this is due to his lack
of focus and he lands next to a ford
focus which yeah focus
focus and ford focus got the best easter
eggs in the world and this back injury
was also referenced by toby maguire and
spiderman noe home andrew garfield and
toby actually ad-libbed a lot of that
scene and it's such a cool callback to
this movie peter then imagines talking
about his problems with uncle ben and
it's pretty much the same luck with the
same set setting clouds as the original
car scene in spider-man 1. the car is a
1973 oldsmobile deltoid 88 which has
appeared in every samuraimi film ever it
showed up in the evil dead at several
points darkman dragged me to hell and it
was of course what ben had in the first
movie now i love that most of spider-man
1 was about peter's regret over this
conversation and how he wanted to very
much live up to the lessons that uncle
ben instilled in him in right he creates
an imaginary purgatory where he has a
conversation with him and still dunks on
his chomp ass see you chump bully
maguire don't stop he even lets someone
get beat up down an alleyway and doesn't
call the police what a [ __ ] now in a
neat bit of returning extras the guy who
is next to peter when the building is on
fire is the same guy he was on the
bridge when peter was saving the kids in
the first movie this scene very much
calls back to the original spider-man
film in which he came face to face with
a green goblin in a building fire
however peter has no superpowers at this
point so it's way more difficult for him
this scene somewhat follows the trope
that a hero loses their powers in a
second movie and it was used in superman
2 and more recently venom let them be
carnage in an interesting moment when
discussing if they should invite peter
to their wedding or not mj asks john to
put his head back and they kiss it's
similar to when peter kisses mj as
spider-man and she tests to see if she
gets the same feeling as back then it's
unclear whether mj knows if peter is
spider-man or not but there's definitely
suspicion there at the end of the first
movie she very much touched her lips
like she recognized the kiss and she
seems slightly let down that her fiance
is not spider-man now in another bit of
foreshadowing when the newspaper flashes
saying he's back there is mention of the
l train safety this is the same train
that peter fights ottawa later in the
movie and it's a really cool setup for
that amazing action scene during the
train fight when peter is giving his
mask back by two kids they're actually
played by toby maguire's real life half
brothers added this the guy who first
stands up to otto is legendary comic and
joe rog and bestie joey diaz making for
some really cool cameos auto hands peter
over to harry who has the same delusions
as his father showing that maybe the
tech that turned osborne crazy simply
exacerbated his insanity now throughout
most of the runs involving harry he very
much ends up following in his father's
footsteps by becoming the green goblin
ultimate spider-man had him become the
hobgoblin and in the recent spider-man
games it looks like he's gonna become
venom after his father's experiments the
legacy of the family is somewhat of a
dark one and in the amazing spider-man 2
we hear of the osborne curse that
eventually leads to him becoming the
green goblin i definitely think that the
movie is teasing that keeping up with
the odds spawns means that you're gonna
get some kind of monster eventually and
that he was potentially always destined
to go this way after finding his
father's hideout in items he appears at
mj's wedding wearing a green bow tie
signifying his fall to the dark side the
movie ends just as it began with a shot
of mj's face showing that the character
has come full circle she says go get him
tiger which is a catchphrase of the
character that has appeared multiple
times in the comics and films she's had
a pretty wild journey in the movies and
dated an astronaut billionaire and also
a superhero plus she was seeing flash
thompson in high school sierra the girls
got game i respect that she was about to
get married to a guy who had to get
several degrees in specific sciences
trained for years so that he could be an
astronaut and then went to the moon just
so that she could run off with someone
who lived in mr dikovich's shittiest
apartment see you chump
it shows that she has chula for the
character and maybe to help pay the
bills she can star on the broadway show
rent thank you good night much love
that's all we've got time for and i hope
you enjoyed the video on screen right
now is some more stuff for you to watch
or you can just let this play out and
see what video youtube chooses for you
you've been a terrific audience and i
hope you've had as much fun as we have
you take care of yourself good night and
i love you peace